Ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen please take your
seats
the program is about to begin
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
14 librarian of Congress Dr. Carla
Hayden
Wow
Good evening and welcome to the 2016
National Book Festival Gala celebration
this is my first public event as the new
Librarian of Congress and you guys
and it's also my first opportunity to
welcome a large gathering to your
Nation's Library
thank you thank you thank you this is a
wonderful wonderful way to begin our
program this evening is being
live-streamed on youtube so thousands of
people outside of this room and outside
of Washington are able to join us and I
think that's so important to be able to
share the collections and programs of
the library of congress with as many
people as possible is my priority is
librarian and it also builds on the
legacy of my 13 predecessors now this
event is one of the highlights every
year and I am honored to be here with
you
it's a national book festival that
brings together our greatest authors
poets illustrators with their many fans
and I'm one of them
that includes all of you joining us here
tonight I want to thank a few people
because no event like this happens
without a lot of work by a lot of
different people we have members of
Congress here the United States Congress
has built and sustain this library and
I'm so appreciative that you're here to
celebrate this achievement the library
of congress is one of the greatest gifts
the legacies that the Congress has given
thank you
also thank you to the embassies of Italy,
Latvia, Mexico, Spain and Uruguay for
providing us with such wonderful talent
for international and food stages i want
to say a special hello to ambassador
Carlos jean le of uruguay who is with us
tonight
also joining us this evening are the
many sponsors who make this event
possible mr. david rubenstein the
festival's co-chair
AARP you make lap the Institute of
Museum and Library Services the
washington post
wells fargo fedex fedex scholastic the
National Endowment for the Arts
the james madison Council of the library
of congress and there are many others
because of your generosity this festival
and I think this is the most important
part is completely free to the public so
thank you thank you thank you
plus there are more than a thousand
volunteers who give their time library
of congress staff the general public the
Junior League of Washington and r
introduces from the Washington Post
national public radio and numerous other
media organizations and speaking of
library staff I have had the privilege
to get to know so many of them in a
short period of time and more than a two
dozen of them have worked for nearly a
year on planning tomorrow's events which
will offer the most of impressive lineup
of authors in the 16-year history of the
festival
I'd especially like to acknowledge
festival organizers guy sue Jean and
Marie please stand up
my first meeting right after the
swearing-in was a briefing on the Book
Festival and i felt like i was at the
command center
it was something and it was filmed by
CNN so you might see it this weekend the
beautiful image you see behind me is our
festival poster it was designed by yuko
shimizu and she wanted to convey the
idea that books take us on journeys they
open up a world of possibilities they
make us ask questions and encourage us
to look for answers they are essential
to the human experience and I remember
my parents giving me books when I was a
little girl and i remember vividly the
moment when I realized those symbols on
a page or words words that translated
into ideas and stories and I was hooked
reading and a love of reading literally
changed my life and as Frederick
Douglass said once you learn to read you
will be forever free you will be free to
explore to dream and make your own
history are wonderful festival
co-chairman the patriotic philanthropist
david rubenstein was also touched by the
powerbooks when he was growing up in
Baltimore his dad would send him to the
any prep free library I know a little
something about that place
where he would check out the maximum
number of books aloud each week 12 he
finished before the week was out and he
has said that the ability to read and
the love of reading quote got me where I
am today and he's called reading one of
the joys of my life and david i do
second that emotion but celebrating
reading as you Nate has enabled us to do
with his extraordinary support of the
national book festival is only a part of
his mission
he's also troubled as many of us are by
the persistent struggles in our country
and around the world with the literacy
his dedication to make sure every child
and adult shares the opportunity and
experience of reading moved him to
establish and support the library of
congress literacy awards the awards
recognize organizations that have made
outstanding contributions to improve
literacy encourage the continuing
development of innovative methods for
combating illiteracy and support the
wide dissemination of the most effective
practices by recognizing current
achievements the awards seek to inspire
others organizations foundations and
other private sector groups to become
involved in battling illiteracy in a few
short years those awards have provided
more than 1 million dollars to support
dozens of organizations both in the
United States and the world
I think there's a video
here at the library of congress it's our
mission
to provide the American people with the
wrench diverse enduring source of
knowledge and the ability to read and
write is critical to fulfilling that
mission
it's why we support the thousands of
organizations around the world
working to promote literacy advocating
for change and empowering families
adults and children to learn to read
invited literacy offer so many life
enhancing benefits people who can read
and do our healthier happier
live longer they are more likely to get
preventative
care and less likely to go to an
emergency global women and girls were
educated at fewer children
do have are twice as likely to survive
everyone benefits from literacy for
every one percent increase in the
country's literacy rate there's a
permanent 1.5% entries in their gross
domestic product
David and women Stein's creative vision
and generosity support the library of
congress literacy awards
each year the literacy awards program
recognizes some of the most innovative
and effective ordinance
promoting literacy
through these awards we celebrate
literacy organizations
your passion and hard work are bringing
education and
proceed to an unprecedented number of
people around the globe we hope to
inspire others to emulate these groups
have to do their part to help
literacy in their own community
beyond we still have a long way to go
together we're making tremendous
progress
please join us in recognizing the
winners of the 2016 library of congress
literacy of American prize-winner
parent-child program International Prize
winner library without borders
david rubenstein prize-winner Devon ETA
Reading Rockets we are grateful to david
rubenstein for his vision and commitment
to literacy in America and throughout
the world more than 60 organizations
have been recognized by the program and
more than 25 million people have been
served by those organizations ladies and
gentlemen please welcome David em
Rubenstein co-chairman of the National
Book Festival and the creator and
sponsor of the library of congress
literacy awards
thank you very much my mother did not
make that movie I i I'm going to I just
express on behalf of all Americans are
delight that carl hayden is now the
library of congress
obviously we've had a lot of great
librarian of Congress but somehow we've
never had a woman be library Congress
we've never had a person of color the
library Congress library of congress and
now we have a perfect combination so I
think it's long overdue and we have a
person who is extraordinarily interested
in books
she has also some other features that i
can't resist mentioning she came from
Baltimore where I'm from
she was the head of the Enoch Pratt
library which gave me my first library
card she has a graduate degree from the
university of chicago as do i and she
loves to read books and encourage other
people to read books and no quality
could be more important in the library
of congress so Carla we're very much
indebted to your for taking this job at
a salary decrease from what you had in
in Baltimore but the public service is
very important and you will be rewarded
in heaven no doubt for having done this
I realize all of you came to hear about
the National Book Festival and it's
spectacular
it's an incredible event it was
conceived of 16 years ago really with an
idea that Laura Bush at the at the
inauguration inaugural events is Jim
Billington the library of congress if
you have a national book festival she
had one of Texas and he said no but
we'll get one and laura bush and he put
it together
it's now incredible event with more than
a hundred thousand people will be there
tomorrow
more than a hundred twenty-five authors
Maria has lined up spectacular groups of
authors many of you were here just as an
American I want to thank you for taking
the time to come here because you can't
imagine how many people are delighted to
meet the authors to hear them read from
the book still have questions of them
and to get autographs from them it's a
spectacular event and as and as the
library and said it's free and so it's
going to be a great event for those who
haven't been there yet you will never
really forget this event we normally do
right go right into her talking to have
some authors and they will you hear them
in a moment but we just thought tonight
would be a good idea just to remind all
of you who love books and everybody here
loves clocks and loves reading books
and loves making certain that other
people are encouraged to read books that
we are a majority but not as much a
majority as we should be
it's hard to believe this but roughly
fourteen percent of americans in our
country the richest country in the world
cannot read they're illiterate
functionally illiterate maybe they can
read a stop sign maybe they can sign
their name a bit but they can't really
read past the third grade level that's
fourteen percent of americans
one-seventh of Americans if you are
illiterate you have a very modest chance
of joining life so many people who
cannot read earn much less on average
about forty percent less than people who
are literate but there are other
problems if you cannot read you have a
much greater chance of going into our
criminal justice system
eighty-five percent of juvenile
delinquents are illiterate and roughly
two-thirds of all the people in our
federal prisons and state prisons are
illiterate so obviously if you cannot
read is a big disadvantage in our
country's his country's ability to give
people the joy of living that they
should get and the end and live up to
all the freedoms that this country is
supposed to be about
so it's a sad situation but it's another
situation is just as important to me and
that's something called a literacy
literacy which means people can read but
she was not to do so this is hard to
believe but roughly thirty percent of
people who graduate from college never
read another book hard to believe and
it's also hard to believe but it's also
true that roughly fifty percent of
americans have not been in a bookstore
or bought a book in the last five years
also hard to believe that roughly
twenty-five percent of americans all
Americans have not read a book in the
last year now this is sad because all of
us know that the pleasure of books is
that it brings you in a different world
it can take you as it did for me from a
modest background into somebody who
really enjoys books can be people all
over the world can have a much richer
life so as tomorrow you are at the
National Book Festival and as you hear
the authors tonight I just like
everybody to think for a moment what can
you do to help improve literacy in this
country illiteracy and all the other
receipt to just think about it in
addition to writing books reading books
and and encouraging people to do so just
think about what event what event you
could be involved with or what
organization you could be involved with
so the organizations that are going to
be honored tonight are terrific
organizations and I appreciate all of
them coming here this evening but they
are really just representing a small
section of the people doing outstanding
work they did outstanding work and we're
going to recognize them but we should
all realize that all of these
organizations need additional financial
support they need your help your ideas
and really if you take take anything
away from this evening and tomorrow it
is that while books are wonderful
we need to encourage people to learn how
to read books and also once they learn
how to read to actually read the books
so I like you're gonna have an enjoyable
evening but a person would like to give
out the awards to the people who won
these awards so when we begin to do so
Mike asked the library of congress
should come up here Carla okay ready
ladies and gentlemen here to receive the
award on behalf of America prize-winner
parent-child home program is Sarah
Walter
yeah
here to receive the award on behalf of
international prize winner libraries
Without Borders is Alistair Chang
yeah
here to receive the award on behalf of
Rubenstein prize-winner weta Reading
Rockets is Sharon Percy Rockefeller
president and CEO of weta and nor
counter
yeah
the check is in the mail and they'll get
the money show up it's very hard to
surprise someone like mr. Rubinstein as
you can imagine but hold on a minute
because you have been so generous and
then he's like what is she doing this is
really fun you have been so generous to
the library to the nation and to so many
people we thought we surprise you with a
special something given by a special
person
guess who this might be given my
we are one of our honored authors is mr.
Kareem abdul-jabbar who is a professor
to in his way and he's an are just
wonderful and he has a special
presentation for you but well okay
yeah
you could imagine what went into the
planning of this
ok
so way they go David thank you don't
matter much I i'm the chair of the board
of Duke University and we never could
beat UCLA when I didn't play at Duke
because to dunk the ball I told them
they had the lower to about 6 feet and
anyway thank you all very much
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
novelist and memory stood Edward daddy
taught us
good evening bonsoir and congratulations
to the $YEAR award winners when an
incredible honor it is to be with you to
be here with all of you tonight being at
one of the first events being hosted by
there are new librarian of Congress
muscala hayden is phenomenal
it's also wonderful to be here in
washington DC on the same weekend that
the National Museum of african-american
history and culture will be officially
opened the ancestors must be rejoicing
just a little bit about this weekend
speaking of ancestors I'm glad that
tonight theme links journeys and
literacy because it gives me an
opportunity to kick off with a line from
our librarian of Congress at her
swearing-in ceremony miss Hayden you
said people of my race were once
punished with lashes and worse for
learning to read my people too and this
is why I often call myself an accident
of literacy i am an accident of literacy
because I risk not existing at all my
parents grew up doing the father-son do
value the cheater ship and Haiti which
lasted from the 1952 the nineteen
eighties the first 12 years of my life
were spent living under that
dictatorship going up in Haiti and your
many children who had a parent killed
sometimes a father before they were born
this often took away the possibility of
their gone being able to go to school in
getting an education i am an accident of
literacy because I might not have been
able to attend school at all had my
parents not journey here to the US like
thousands of immigrants some of whom are
being deported today parents who have no
choice but to leave their countries
their family
and even their children behind for the
possibility of a better life elsewhere i
am an accident of literacy because it is
the money earned from my parents working
sometimes two jobs sometimes around the
clock in New York sweatshops factories
kitchens and car washes their salaries
from these jobs paid for me to start on
my journey to learning to read and write
I am an accident of literacy because
when i was able to join my parents here
in the United States at age 12 if we
were undocumented I might have been shut
out of the public schools that
eventually allowed me to learn English
and put me on a path towards reading and
writing and my adopted tongue I am an
accident of literacy become some
libraries might have refused me entry or
access or library card they might have
put up a wall between me and those
hundreds and hundreds of books that i
didn't know i needed wanted to help me
imagine a better journey and a life
beyond the barred windows of my family's
cram two-bedroom apartment in Brooklyn
I am an accident of literacy because
even though I was new to the United
States and you to english some of my
teachers refrained from telling me that
certain words thoughts ideas and dreams
were unavailable to me i'm an accident
of literacy because all those things
that could have happened to me did not
and part because of struggles that
others have fought and continue to fight
today I always tell people when they ask
my best writing teachers were that they
were the storytellers of my childhood my
grandmother's and odds who are not all
readers some of them were not even
literate but they carried stories like
treasures inside of them and every once
in a while on a dark night when the
lights were out or even when they were
on their would tell me stories because
there were some things that they did not
want me to forget that did not want me
to forget what it is like to laugh to be
afraid to feel sadness and to feel joy
or sometimes within the scope of a
single-story to these great stories
sellers videos contours or downstairs
every story was a gift that you carry
with you until it was your turn to pass
it on
and even if you did not understand the
story fully as it was being told to you
one day it would become clearer when
some event will show up in your life
when you would need a story most on your
path on your journey and that story
would appear again like an ancestor or
an air someone yet to be born which is
why this wonderful celebration of
literacy also makes me think of so many
both here in the US as mr. Rubenstein
said and around the world for him
literacy is still beyond reach either
for political or socio-economic reasons
many are not allowed to read and write
or can't afford to learn to read and
write
there's is one of the shadows that dims
some of our joy as we celebrate literacy
and the individuals writers librarians
and institutions like this one that
nurtures and supports literacy as which
would write wrote and is 1945 more black
boy after borrowing a white men's
library card and forging his handwriting
so he could borrow books from the
library right wrote that quote reading
can be a passion a hunger too great to
be contained words can also be used as
weapons or counter weapons words help us
experience the deaths of what is
possible for us and others which is why
literacy is so often closely monitored
suppress or forbidden by oppressors
bigots dictators tyrants and they're
like and maybe this is why our ancestors
might be a little bit please tonight in
this entire weekend because not only are
we celebrating reading and writing
literacy in the word but we are also
celebrating some like a wonderful new
librarian of Congress who have become
living stories as well thank you
yeah
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
science writer James click
thank you thank you I'm so happy to be
here I'm honored to be here especially
at at the very beginning of what's going
to be called the Hayden era
I've just been i've been working on a
book about time travel for a while and
when it when I told people I was working
on a book about time travel i got all
kinds of different reactions but i think
my favorite was a woman who said cool
have you ever done it and I have a
feeling that she was disappointed by my
answer because of course nobody actually
gets to hop into a DeLorean and speed
into the past and meet our parents as
teenagers we can't plug ourselves down
in the saddle of a time machine and turn
the lever that sends us to the 31st
century much as we might want to meet
them there aren't actually time
travelers from the future
walking in our midst still nowadays time
machines are a great cultural totem the
time machine is a well-known movie
actually all slew of movies and TV shows
and comics and everything else but of
course first and foremost before all of
that the time machine is a book it was a
little book the american edition was
sold in New York by the publisher Henry
hold for 75 cents
eventually the young man who wrote it hg
wells became an international celebrity
historian a visionary champion of world
government but in 1895 he was just a son
of shopkeepers fresh out of school
desperately hoping to make a living as a
writer he wrote The Time Machine and
rewrote it again and again working late
at night by the light of a paraffin lamp
and finally found a publisher who paid
him a hundred pounds for it
it wasn't easy to make a career out of
writing books in Victorian England but
it was possible Wells wrote to a friend
someday I shall succeed i really believe
but it is a weary game in 21st century
America it's possible to make a career
out of writing books but it isn't easy
and forces of technology and commerce
are combined and can make it harder
every year for Young Writers I think we
all know that our commitment to literacy
and our commitment to the writing life
have to be inseparable one and the same
I have time traveled by the way and so
have you all readers and writers there
was a massacre in haiti in 1937 all but
forgotten head we don t car takes us
there
in 1914 Theodore Roosevelt hauled and
paddled dugout canoes down the river of
gout in the Amazon rainforest Candace
Maillard takes us there
we can leave our busy electric present
and turn the clock back 60 years to a
small iowa town where a dying pastor is
preserving his memories and reconnecting
with his own past and the clock Turner
is Marilynne Robinson and of course a
lot of writers aren't busy recreating
the past instead they're trying to
invent the future our best sense of the
future and and maybe our worst since the
future we can hope for the future we
should fear they both come from the
imaginations of writers you want to take
a journey we are all time travelers
nowadays and the book is our time
machine and the library is time travel
headquarters which I guess makes the
library of congress the time-travel
Pentagon and I mean that in the nicest
possible way
the great Ursula K Le Guin put it this
way story is our only boat for sailing
on the river of time
thank you
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
historian Candice Miller
thank you i can't tell you what an
incredible honor it is for me to be here
among so many distinguished authors and
I had just the unbelievable privilege of
meeting dr. Hayden earlier tonight and i
will never forget it
so thank you so much for allowing me to
be here and I grew up in a small town in
Ohio and it was a great place to grow up
it was safe that people were nice
there are a lot of woods and streams and
ponds that froze over in the winter so
we could skate on them but if I look
back at my childhood the happiest
moments I had were spent in the library
and it was a great library
it was in this old two-story red brick
building with wide front steps and add a
small room in the front for children's
books and had high ceilings and creaky
wood floors and it smelled like old
books if it was a nice day or even a
cold one I used to sit outside on the
front steps and I would dangle my legs
over the side and I would feel the Sun
on my face and I would read the books
that i just picked out and I was never
happier than in those moments then one
day when I was about 9 years old I went
to the library who walk there from my
house and I saw this small vertical
revolving rack of paperback books and
there's this handwritten paper sign on
top of them with just one word and it
said free and we had always had books in
my house because we always went to the
library but i didn't have very many
books that were mine that actually
belong to me so i stood in front of that
revolving rack and i turned it and i
turned it around and around and these
weren't children's books so I didn't
know any of them but one finally caught
my eye and it was called i know why the
caged bird sings and again I was just
this
kid from this little working-class town
in Ohio so I had never heard of this
book I had no idea what was about
I had no idea who my angela was I just
like the title on the cover so i pulled
it off the rack and I slipped in my
pocket and I brought it home and I
didn't know it at the time but that walk
that small journey from the library back
to my house passed a hardware store and
the elementary school and JB's we're
used to stop to get deep fried mushrooms
that walk I had made a thousand times
before would be different this time
because I began to read i know why the
caged bird sings of course at nine a lot
of it confused me and some of it scared
me but for the first time I realized
that books could be more than just
entertaining or educational they could
be beautiful and they could be moving
and they cannot just teach me that they
could transport me as I grew older books
became not less important to me but even
more i turned the books when i went to
Ethiopia on assignment for National
Geographic for the first time and I was
scared I wasn't scared because I was an
Ethiopian I loved it there I was scared
because I was new at this
this was my big chance and I knew that I
was gonna mess up so every night tired
and worried I would climb into my
sleeping bag under my mosquito net and I
would reach from my book and instantly I
would be in another world a world in
which whatever happened it wasn't my
fault and I didn't have to worry about
it the next day I could just be whisked
away i also turned the books when my
husband and I had a child who was born
with cancer and every night in the
hospital when she fell asleep i would
sit in a corner of her room with a
bottle of water
and I'm some beef jerky from the vending
machine and a little book light and
harry potter and in a flash I would be
in hogwarts far away from all the tears
of the day so all that I can hope from
the books that i right is that they
might be a comfort to someone somewhere
at some time I know that there are
people who think the idea of a book
being your friend is ridiculous but i
think that there's absolutely nothing
wrong with that on the contrary I think
it's a shame not to have books that are
your friends and when I think of
literacy when I think of what it must
mean to not be able to read i think that
it is a deprivation not just of
knowledge minh knowledge enlightenment
and opportunity although it is all of
those things but it also denies a
powerful source of refuge and friendship
Winston Churchill who was not only a
voracious reader but an extraordinarily
talented writer who supported himself
for 70 years with his writing who won
the nobel prize for literature said that
if you cannot read all of your books at
any rate . to them let them fall open
where they will read from the first
sentence that arrest see I set them back
in their shows with your own hands
arrange them on your own plan so that if
you do not know what is in them
you at least know where they are let
them be your friends i still have my
first copy of i know why the caged bird
sings I brought it with me tonight
it's coming a long journey with me over
many decades and too many places and it
will always be one of my most treasured
possessions but more than that it will
always be my friend
thank you
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
novelist and winner of the 2016 library
of congress prize for American fiction
Marilynne Robinson good evening it's a
wonderful honor to be here
sometimes you know this this building is
a celebration much more than a monument
and to be included in an event of this
kind and to be among the people that
sustain it didn't love it is a very very
moving thing I taught writing for a long
time to gifted writers and very whoo-hoo
enriched my life for many years with
their brilliance and grace and while i
tought i talked about experiences of my
own that made me feel the importance of
the qualitative significance of of
reading these are some a couple of
not-quite anecdotes that i often
mentioned with my students and in any
case I remember quite distinctly what it
was like when the difficulties of my new
literacy my marginal literacy somehow
became the utter trance of childhood
book business when the resistance
offered by unknown words and complicated
sentences fell away before my absorption
in almost any book that fell into my
hands when children love book the
experience they find in them is one side
and engrossing like a dream I realize
how important it is to me now to have
been haunted and enchanted by it ground
pole to have left myself to tears over
the lesser works of Mark Twain to have
been given the collected poems of Emily
Dickinson by
my big brother the sense of progressive
initiation has been part of it all
through my whole life together with an
impulse and desire to speak into that
great conversation and experience like
this has been the privilege of very few
people historically very few human
beings it waited on the technology of
printing and publishing on public
libraries and on the historically recent
assumption that literacy should be the
Norman society now it is hard to
remember that it is individually and
achievement and collectively a privilege
and that the modern world is unique in
the extraordinary degree that it is
structured by and permeated by written
language we tend to think of things that
are fruitful as if they are to be valued
for their utility we forget how
objectively wonderful they are i have
had a few opportunities to speak with
people who are or who have been
incarcerated
typically they have come to reading late
or at least from marginal literacy to
actual literacy for reasons that are
familiar to all of us
they have been brought to books by
boredom and loneliness and restlessness
with the thought that they are excluded
from knowledge of another life
one man told me that he had been
drifting from bad to worse and then i
read a book he said that was the first
time I realized that the world was
something i could be interested in the
fruitfulness I've spoke of is the change
in this man's life in his mind without
reference to potential contributions to
society which might very well be modest
as these things are conventionally
reckoned anyone who remembers being
struck and moved by a book knows
something of
this experience and knows that it is an
excellent thing in itself a real
liberation without any reference to
practical consequences i mentioned these
conversations because they have made me
particularly aware of what we as a
community give people or deny them when
we make them fully literate or leave
them in a state of exclusion most of us
cannot imagine remind me also that the
written word is unaccountably rich and
powerful applications in the matter of
food and drink and the light of the Sun
and here we are the wealthiest country
in history wondering darkly about the
wisdom of our investment in the
humanities well our children enhance a
corporate profit margin as a result of
reading even studying leaves of grass
quite possibly
I think the question being mulled really
is whether we should invest so much
social wealth in providing a great part
of our population with an acquaintance
at least with their human heritage sting
genus creeps it finds its own logic in
irrefutable increasingly public assets
are spoken of as public burdens why
after all locked up so much exploitable
welcome national parks do we really need
all these great universities we the
public could be impoverished radically
before we understood the nature of the
Los an incarcerated woman said to me
tell your students to write good books
they're all we live for what would it
matter if that sustenance were denied to
her who would even know this is a
metaphysical question so is the disputed
value of the astonishing the astonishing
communion we have among ourselves
mediated by books how we value her
solitary obscure human life how much
well we are honored to share with her
will speak directly to the kind of
civilization we are and will become this
great library is a proof of the value I
society has placed in the world of in
the world civilization of readers
writers in books
I cannot begin to reckon the pure good i
have taken from American fiction
american libraries American education
the prizes at this price that i will
receive is profoundly gratifying to me
thank you
thank you thank you to all of our
inspirational authors members of
Congress and sponsors to those of you
watching at home i hope you will join us
tomorrow at the convention center or
tune into c-span book TV or PBS few
books you now who the broadcasting live
from the National Book Festival and i
will be tweeting the entire day
and now would you please join me in the
great hall for buffet supper and enjoy
the festival
yeah